Asgardians Leviosa we're gonna watch a
mighty raccoon Thor V Thanos F s what
Conda battle Avengers infinity war
alternate ending never too late to do an
alternate ending for infinity war this
is a great fantastic channel ladies and
gentlemen I wanted to say if you haven't
done so already why haven't you
downloaded and follow us on the Stardust
app we mentioned it countless times and
yes we grow every day over there that's
because we post daily 30-second reviews
for films TV shows and trailers you can
post to whole thing is completely free
to use participate yourself okay I'm
done
[Music]
you won't hear us echoing any event
[Music]
[Music]
like a student film in a park deep fake
for like a skid mud come on to work
prevent endgame from ever happening
yeah
it only looks like a video game is
[Laughter]
short-lived
[Music]
huh we're all okay guys yeah it's over
now how do we get back from Titan
no except vision did
[Music]
they wrote this little sketch right here
hate it yeah so for a commitment to put
just showing the credit favreau James
Gunn Stanley all those guys they love
this this has been a cancel James Gunn
although they did reveal that his wife
was in fact the abuser I got my facts
very correct
trust me I'm crazy how mighty raccoons
team has grown over time to include most
of the emcee who's creative stuff yeah
you know what I did appreciate about
this one yes it's a short-lived fight
maybe Thor could have done those things
it did kind of make me wonder when I was
watching infinity war of why he just
didn't still kill him anyway it's kind
of like he he waited I don't know what
the timeline is of that because look at
it from the movies perspective right you
should have gone for the head he snaps
Thor's like what have you done and then
you know Danice vanishes so I don't know
what the timeline is a bit was Thor just
like watching Thanos the whole time
going or did that all this happen all at
once in like the matter of a couple of
seconds from his snap and four dead set
it right there or was he just you know
having a really insanely long delayed
reaction there's that thought that I had
so this this concept of him going after
him and you know throwing some lighting
at him and then eventually deciding to
cut off his head that's cool it looked
cool too cool fantasy what I appreciated
in terms of narrative and I don't know
if this is what you were going for this
is just what I picked up on that even
though in this version they beat Thanos
they won vision did die before this
moment happened this still ends on them
mourning the loss of vision which is
what our heroes I think would do despite
the fact that there is this big
triumphant heroic moment that they beat
the big baddie they still lost an
integral
for someone they love dearly who and
they'd never want to lose anyone so I
would imagine that if this scenario did
even play out in infinity war the movie
itself they would focus on the loss of
vision so I do like that oh yeah one the
road to this battle is so long and
arduous anyway that by the time it's
over if it did in this way I got imagine
everyone would just kind of let it all
kind of just dissipate out from
themselves because you know what else
can you do at that moment when you're
that exhausted from fighting you know so
yeah it's like it does become this
weirdly somber victory after you know
everything I guess it could have
happened like that is funny I was
thinking about that too and I think that
in the movie it's probably just movie
time just sort of like uh yeah we're
showing a much things but it's all
happening this play second but what I
really think should have happened is
Thor should have aimed for the nuts
because if he'd hit Thanos in the nuts I
don't think he'd even have had that
moment to be like I'm still gonna snap
the fingers like he would be so
distracted he would use the time stone
to go back to make sure he was never hit
in the nuts in the nuts that's right and
then he would do this thing there's no
way to win try any and it's like nuts
man they they're very distracting when
they're in pain amen things straight
thanks thanks man what I find funny
about what mighty raccoon does with
these alternate endings kind of makes me
flash to the ones that he did with the
Hulk vs. Thanos there's never really uh
much of a fight put up my tents in these
they're so quick it's like Hulk
I mean beat the crap out of that house
very fast that it's gonna put up a fight
at all and the same thing here like
panelists would have been able to put up
a little bit of a fight but I also do
credit him in terms of creating this
little short narrative taking footage
earlier from infinity war when they're
on the planet tied in to make it look
like that's the ending wrap of that
really that's like yeah I feel like
Fanus is dead no that's how you get the
vibe he's dead you know filters the
group Society relief throughout the
universe as a Star Wars movie they would
say the force and justify it like that
you know that's how it goes but the main
issue with this alternate ending is
there wouldn't be my favorite MCU movie
of all time
Avengers end game well I think a lot of
people
issue had gone that way you know if we
just won in one movie yeah he did the
second part you know would have been a
lot more efficient I think we could have
all moved on to phase four a lot sooner
so you're the minority Greg I don't
think anybody like that very true very
true very cool very cool very cool I
wonder how this would have played if you
made everything computer why didn't you
do more work for the free content that
you're giving us mighty raccoon it
should have animated everything you
should make a whole video game out of
this of the we can all defeat Thanos in
infinity war has our favorite of it and
it should be free-to-play alright I
criticize the free stuff you put in a
frequent downloadable upgrades to it
just keep on pumping and we'll never pay
for it huh that's what Thanos said about
is okay alright reject nation if you
haven't done so already make sure to
subscribe to mighty raccoon and hey why
don't you somehow link one of the stones
to this pun that I was not clever enough
to come up with by subscribing and
clicking the notification bell to our
channel and hitting the like button as
well and make sure download falls on the
start a snap also it's time for a patron
of the day shout out today's patient the
day shout-out goes to a man named Tyler
hey you've heard us talk plentiful about
this handsome gentleman sexy guy sexy
guy Tyler said that for his new year's
resolution he's got a couple of main
goals one to lose some weight
everyone says that even skinny people
say that yeah it's ridiculous number two
he wants to come out to California again
and he wants to meet us and
simultaneously within that one he wants
to go to galaxy's edge so Tyler it's the
deal that's been struck when you come
out here we're all going to galaxy's
edge together and by we that means John
is making the promise to sacrifice all
yes and financials to yo this galaxy
edge
I might have to back out you know based
off of circumstances but John will
definitely go money I'll do what I can
though
make sure I can go with you because I
love you but I might not be able to
attend if it's just the two of us we can
make it work we can cuddle we can get a
turkey leg together you know we can ride
it's a small world we can get in the
teacups we can take a vlog and rub it in
Greg's face yeah yeah I will definitely
be jealous
yes as he sits at home playing
PlayStation 4
[Laughter]
you